a note to all you struggling
screenwriters out there who are looking
for your big break if you make a movie
about possession that's even halfway
decent or even a big piece of [ __ ]
Hollywood will probably make it they
love possession movies are there that's
your way in advice from me the
possession so the possession is yet
another movie about possession and
another Halloween movie that's coming
out in August which is I guess that's
the thing to do now so in the possession
you have a split up family now you have
the chick from the closer and you have
the comedian from Watchmen whose name I
can't remember it's a bummer because the
dudes a good actor third divorce they
have these two little kids and the
comedian's like I want to be a good dad
so yeah okay you can buy that really
creepy piece of [ __ ] box from the garage
sale when you see a creepy ass little
antique at a garage sale don't buy it
cuz it's probably possessed or cursed
this is life survival 101 right there
however they buy this creepy box and now
this girl's slowly getting possessed and
she's losing her mind and you know
demons and [ __ ] and when watching the
movie you're like yeah I've been here
before
truth be told the first hour and 15
minutes of this movie it's all build-up
and it's actually quite boring it's just
kind of boring there's a bunch of
characters you don't care about this
little girls you know she's all crazy
and creepy and being possessed as little
kids do nowadays but hats off to the
comedian from Watchmen that guy carried
the first hour 15 minutes of this movie
he's the one who actually had witty
dialogue or realistic dialogue
I actually liked his character people
were like oh you're never there for your
kids but I thought he was an alright guy
I mean I was like [ __ ] give the guy a
break he's a single dad who actually has
witty dialogue so their chick from The
Closer always baffles my mind to movies
like this when people are like oh that
box is evil what to do wood chippers
haven't been around forever let's not
try that I would try the wood chipper I
would but in the first hour and 15
minutes of this movie being kind of slow
and having some choppy editing in parts
someone will be freaking out the black
and then I'll just cut you're like okay
that was a cool effect but when they do
it five times in a row you're like
getting old man however the last half
hour of this movie is actually really
creepy and really cool like if the
possession was a half an hour special
featured on the History Channel which
would make sense because the History
Channel really doesn't have anything to
do with history anyway not anymore I
would watch it I'd be thoroughly
entertained for the half hour be like oh
that's cool yeah let's just watch this
for half an hour but it wasn't it's a
movie that you're gonna pay money to see
you're going to be bored for an hour and
15 minutes into the movie in the last
half hour you're gonna be like oh cool
awesome where was this why did this just
kick in now supposedly the possessions
based on a true story which okay there's
I mean this is kind of a spoiler not a
spoiler the little girl gets a cat-scan
and you see the demon in ER so does the
hospital have that recording it's based
on a true story if that happened then
they have the recording I would like to
see that please that's just me I require
proof like that I'm just saying you
could put a lot of speculation to rest
if you just have the recording of creepy
demon face if not well it's probably not
based on the true story or it's based on
a true story the sense that yeah there
was a divorced family who heard crickety
Crick's in the house yeah I would
actually I'd buy that so hats off to the
comedian some really creepy cool ass
[ __ ] the last half-hour of this movie
and if I graded the movie on the last
half hour it would get a pretty good
rating however I got to write the movie
as a whole in since the first hour and
15 minutes of this movie bored me I will
say the possession is a good time if
you're drunk ya know it's a party I got
you and a special thank you to Ren aka
Ren the Reaper for making that new slick
intro for me it's badass I love it thank
you and he actually made two fonts I
want your opinion what font do you
prefer for the intro this one
or this one I'm curious what ever you
prefer comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]